hello and welcome to this video playing
in India ye okay probably doing
something wrong there in Indonesia okay
so we got the got a Scandinavian
I think nowadays everybody calls it a
Scandinavian I knew that there was also
the term sent a counter defense at some
point but now it's all scandi
except us the moment where you play
three there's one line anyway you should
play a three so that's C for 93 years
hopes is a neighborhood without having
to worry about tonight - before I think
this is probably the position
[Music]
you
often you should play h3 which I did not
to do now up to this point let's do it
now before Bishop g4 happens who came
it's gained some space I honestly never
understood the appeal of this particular
Scandinavian line with Knight f6 because
I mean white is always just better with
the little effort
it is not much let's say when riders are
not winning or anything but just feels
like I put like every I put every piece
in the center and and then black is
somewhat running out of moves
maybe this is a simplistic view and
wrong but this is what I oftentimes
experience honestly I think my queen is
not really well placed 72 I should
probably put it away away from the D
file maybe he's got some ePHI of stuff
I don't know my idea now is to play see
595 takes rook takes Bishop c4
okay this is interesting
hmm what is black doing here
I could play a for even a 45 sediment
No
yeah it's even more space
maybe just knight c6 now for black this
yeah this is something that I had on the
raid how I didn't quite
think it was a problem
so not easy to it's not easy to find a
clear-cut way for but I mean black is
just sitting down and now I have a way
forward
was one problem couldn't she never had a
square for the g7 right
probably take this first
you
so I'm a piece up my king is a little
bit insecure
[Music]
just a little bit bishop - gee - it's a
good way to secure it and I'm attacking
b7 and intend to c5 so let's push put
him away
[Music]
I don't think I need to delay this
you
rather use the pieces that I have
instead of like trying to consolidate
you can just use the
additional piece with d6 coming
95 is also on the agenda I've got
everything covered it's always
reassuring if you have absolutely not a
single unprotected piece it's very
unlikely that something bad happens it's
really a good indicator
yeah I don't know can you take the six I
thought Bishop c5 and okay he doesn't
just doesn't try that okay I was very
helpful that he blunder but I'd never
understood what the appeal of this
liners well I mean there's a whole book
written about it by David's mode and
this Snowden Scandinavian and I know it
sounds very simplistic but if you do
this the check and like play d4 Knight
f3 c4 white is just better forever so I
don't see the point of this opening I
mean you get at best a slightly inferior
game but it's inferior forever like like
with this it looks like a bad form of a
scanned as overall vanilla cones just
just centralize everything in three
Queen no age six before you know I think
maybe I have some improvement here
I would like a set up with Queen to b3
but I cannot do it now because d4 is
hanging I would actually the engine
wants to do this probably you cannot
take
no matter is not so convincing orally
or it says some other trick a bishop
james tape ting ting 595 now that I do
understand yeah that is said is
certainly better for which a position
like that must be must be better
yeah that is quite comfortable maybe
this is more precise than than Queen d2
yeah and and this is the problem you get
to this this kind of position with black
and then you're stuck you don't know
what to do I can always try like a for
wine and and I'm just I just have
everything under control yeah
so what is blacks plane I don't see it
and you you always get to this kind of
stuff in this in this line I don't know
what the point is honestly yeah so g4 h
4s already recommended by the comp but
you know let's do this a 5v5 yeah now he
gave me the game with 96 I mean again
this this cannot be right yeah but it's
still very solid I mean what you can do
with black is you can just sit and wait
and hope that the other guy makes a
mistake and try to convert the space
advantage but it's very attractive and I
honestly don't know if you can never
avoid it I always think it leads to this
kind of stuff yeah correct me if I'm
wrong if you a specialist in this line
or whatever you can look it up maybe
you'll find something but I always think
it leads to this kind of situation and
then always put me off of the d5 Knight
f6 Scandinavian not even those sharp
lines I mean you can argue that there is
some there is this this famous line I
think the Portuguese is called this is
probably also incorrect but it's so
complicated that you can definitely play
it but I always thought this pointless
you just play Bishop b5 in a better
forever a bit better bit better forever
okay yes thanks for watching